what i want to do now is simplify the
exact same expression but would do it
with traditional algebraic long division
and hopefully we'll see why synthetic
division actually gives us the exact
same result we'll be able to see the
connections between synthetic division
and algebraic long division so let's get
started so if we're doing algebraic long
division and set it up right over here
the first thing we want to think about
is how many times does the highest
degree term here which is our x go into
the highest degree term here which is
our three x to the third power
well x goes into three x to the third
power three x squared times so we'll
write it in the x squared place three
x squared times
now you might already see your parallel
when we did the synthetic division we
dropped this 3 straight down and this 3
represented 3 x squared so this 3 and
this 3x squared are really representing
the same thing but you might be saying
well how you know here we have to do
some thinking we have to say x goes into
three x to the third three x square
times here we just mindlessly drop this
three straight down how did that work
the reason why we were able to
mindlessly drop this 3 straight down is
because we assumed to do this basic type
of synthetic division that we had just
an x right over here we didn't have a 3x
we didn't have a 4x we didn't have an x
squared we just had an x and if you
divide an x into whatever this first
whatever this highest degree term is
your coefficient is going to be the
exact same thing it's just going to be 1
degree lower so you go from a 3x to the
third to 3x squared so the exact same
coefficient and now in our little
synthetic division right over here this
is the x that right over there is the x
squared term so you went from 3x to the
third to 3x squared we essentially
divided it by x and we could blindly do
it because we knew we assumed that we
were dealing with just a one x a one x
to the first right over here but let's
keep on going and see the parallels and
see why we're essentially doing the
exact same thing now let's take this 3x
squared and multiply that times x plus
4. so 3x squared times x is going to be
i'll do that white color it's going to
be 3
x to the third and 3x squared times 4 is
going to be
is going to be 12
x squared
and now we'll want to subtract this
so now we subtract
we subtract this out
and we are left with these guys cancel
out and you have 4x squared minus 12x
squared and so that will give you
negative
negative 8x squared so once again you're
probably seeing some parallels you had
the 4x squared over here you have the 4x
squared over there we just wrote the
coefficient but that's what it
represented 4x squared we wrote the 4
there then we essentially subtracted 12x
squared and the way we got that 12 we
multiplied 3 times four three times four
and then we subtracted here we're
multiplying three times negative four
we're essentially multiplying three
times four and then subtracting that's
why we put that negative there so we
don't have to keep remembering to
subtract this row so we could just keep
adding them but that's essentially what
we did we multiplied 3 times this 4 and
now we subtract it we get that negative
12x squared and then we subtract it and
you got negative 8x squared and you
might say oh is this the same negative 8
as this right over here not quite yet to
do the to because over here this
negative 8 literally represents negative
8 x this is actually part of our
simplification when we divide this into
that we got 3x squared minus 8x plus 30.
so over here in the algebraic long
division
we then say how many times does x plus 4
go into negative 8x squared well x goes
into negative 8x squared
negative eight x times
so this is the key right over here x
goes into it negative
negative eight
negative eight x times and once again
the reason why we could just put this
negative 8 here is we know that we are
dividing just by a 1x so you're going to
have the exact same coefficient the
exact same coefficient just one degree
lower so this right over here is our x
term and you see it right over there
just like that so a lot of
simplification just comes from the idea
that we are assuming with the synthetic
division that this is a 1x but let's
just keep going so you have a negative
8x times this business right over here
gives you negative 8x times x is
negative
8 x squared and then you have negative
8x times 4
which is which is negative
32
negative 32x and we can bring down all
of this business right over here just so
it becomes a little bit simpler so you
have a negative 2x and then over here
you have a minus 1.
and once again when you're doing
traditional algebraic long division
you're going to subtract this from that
up there so if we're going to subtract
that's like adding the negative
and so we are left with these characters
cancel out you have a negative 2x plus
32x that gives us a positive 30x a
positive 30x and then we can bring down
that negative 1 if we want so we bring
down i'll do that yellow color actually
we'll bring down that negative 1.
so this 30 has the same coefficient here
but this 30 should be up here this is
going to be part of our final answer and
to get that once again it all comes from
the fact that we know that we had an x
here when we did the synthetic division
30x divided by x is just going to be 30
is just going to be 30. that 30 and this
30 is the exact same thing and then we
multiply 30 times x
is 30x
30 times 4 is actually write the 30x in
that white color because that's the
convention i've been using
30x 30 times 4 is 120
and then we are going to subtract and
then we're going to subtract this from
that so we get we get negative 1 minus
120 is negative 121
negative 121 which is which right over
there is our remainder which is exactly
exactly what we got over there so
hopefully you see the connection this
because we are assuming that we're
dividing by x plus or minus something we
were able to make some simplifying
assumptions whenever you divide this by
an x you know it's going to have the
same coefficient just one degree lower
same coefficient one degree lower and we
kept doing that and so it allowed us to
do it a little bit simpler a little bit
faster and using less space